[Music]  check outside  I gotta tell you something pal you still  got it  you got every move though you with debts  I'm sorta tight Frenchy believe me story  for another time  dude these three pigs were in we're out  where you say you serious  really yeah is this it's called a car  mate no it's a wheelchair with a real  frenchie it's clean it's quiet and ever  smell like your laughs on the inside all  right we have to first then Las Vegas go  with you does the English shoe salesman  nobody's talking to of noise push the  ball around so you already prepared the  referees let's have it if the bag to mr.  French  sure problem she gave it up work too  easy French okay  [Music]  thumping violence brothers I'm done and  with varnas what's that supposed to make  it means no more her than my fellow man  [Music]  [Music]  good job with the non-violence thing by  the way at dinner real good job that  might impressive  [Music]  you